we are at the tail end of the topic
nature of proof uh i don't know if it
feels like we've been in there a long
time
or a short time uh today's lesson you
guys know we've introduced a whole bunch
of new
language and ideas and concepts to you
this one's going to
feel probably the most inverted commas
it's all maths but this will feel
the most familiar mathematical that
you've done since the start of the year
is my expectation so we're going to be
talking about
inequalities as the heading states and
you have to be quite cautious
with these objects right because they
seem
really familiar but they're actually i'm
gonna suggest
dangerously different in at least three
key ways all of which we'll need to keep
in mind
for the proofs we're going to do today
so let's have a think about each one in
turn number one
we're really good at dealing with
equations like
really really good if you're here in
this room you're an expert at them
but when it comes to equations versus
inequalities
if i hear you an equation with no like
verb no question
no keyword with it what would you expect
is the thing you need to do
to that equation to finish the question
what do you think
it's like an equation on the board
you're like oh
what do i do with this thing what's the
operative verb
solve so find x right so i'm trying to
find a solution
for this and your brain is quite wired
to do that and kind of this like
here's the direction that i'm headed in
right but you cannot really
in the context of this topic think about
solving an inequality i mean i can just
turn this into an inequality and i can
still ask you
to solve it but we're actually going to
be dealing with i mean what's the topic
again
proof we're proving inequalities as
you're gonna see
it's quite a different mentality that's
involved okay there's the first
difference
the second difference is when you get an
inequality right when you get into
quality
besides as the name suggests they're
different
they're different right that's what
unequal inequality
means that has some really weird
implications because
for instance if i said to you 10 is
greater than 7 which is a fairly
uncontroversial statement
right i can say 10 is greater than 7
that
implies that 10
is greater than 6 and you're like well
of course numerically that makes sense
to us
but just think about the difference from
this
compared to if we were back in equation
land right
you don't just go ahead and say i
actually don't like that half being
there
just gonna change it to something else
right that doesn't fly when we're
dealing with equations
but with inequalities you can do
different things
to both sides of the eq of the
inequality and sometimes you have to or
there's no other way
to go about it let me give you let me
give you a more um concrete example
that's
more controversial than say this can you
um get your pen out right
suppose you were being asked to prove
it was some expression with a bunch of
x's in it maybe it was a
an exponential or a polynomial or
trigonometric function
something with x's in it and we want you
to prove that it's bigger than
well let's just go with six right now
you may get asked to start manipulating
this thing start working with it
and i have students when they're
attempting this question right they go
through all their working
and then they get to some line that
looks like this and they're like
oh no what have i done wrong now of
course you've done nothing
wrong if the thing that you're
interested in you want to make it prove
that it's bigger than six well you just
prove that it's
even bigger than bigger than six so from
here you directly go to this line
but that's just a whole different
mindset from how you dealt with
inequalities that make sense
okay and then thirdly last caution
inequalities have direction don't they
right uh when you think about
equations here right i can just flip
this around makes no difference
yeah but of course our left and our
right hand side here
are very very different let me give you
some quick examples
again using our language from
earlier in the topic if a is greater
than
b that means i can say
if and only if when i multiply both
sides
by a negative like say negative 1 what
does that tell you about the direction
of the inequality
it's it's switched has it not
10 is bigger than 6 but negative 10
is less than negative 6. you're happy
with that okay
there are other situations where you
have to mind the direction
of the inequality and say for example do
the same thing
to both sides same thing to both sides
same operation
but you still have to flip the direction
of the inequality can someone give me an
example
have a think is greater than b
i'll give you a clue um this one's about
multiplication right the most obvious
one you're going to encounter
has to do with the opposite of
multiplication with division right
division's something that you have to be
careful with these as well because
multiplication and division they're kind
of like the same operation looked at
from two different points of view
so if for instance i took the reciprocal
of both sides
right this is something you can do with
equations happy times right
1 over this should equal 2. i'll take
the reciprocal of both sides
happy times but that's not the case here
what was our example 10 is bigger than 6
a 10th is definitely less than a 6.
make sense so we have to mind the fact
that even when you're doing the same
thing to both sides
you actually have to deal with the
direction of it here because we don't
know the style of a
and b so if you take reciprocal dragon
cannot
yeah that's right it gets even more
confusing when you start to think about
well
what values can a and b take on
mercifully for you guys we are going to
be thinking about positive negative
but no complex numbers when you think
about inequalities right you actually
can't
say that a complex number is bigger and
you know is bigger than and nothing else
than another complex number you can say
their magnitudes are different
you can say the angles are different but
this is that two-dimensional nature of
it right which one is
greater is this greater or is
this greater right so we don't worry
about
order when we talk about complex numbers
everything we're about to do
under this part will be in the real
number world make sense
okay under this heading make a little
subheading for me which is
strategies what are in my in view of
these
cautions one of the strategies we can
use to prove the sets
of inequalities that we're going to be
provided i've got
three main ones for you number one
we were just actually jail is just sort
of flagging it right number one has to
do with
sign to do with positives or negatives
so say for instance let's switch over to
where's my black on
let's say for example you wanted to
prove that some a
is bigger than some b okay so if we're
required to
prove a is greater than b then a and b
could be anything it could be a whole
function could be a number
etc one of the ways we can do this is we
can think
there are some operations that preserve
the direction of the inequality
addition and subtraction are generally
okay yeah so i could do something like
this
these are equivalent statements i know i
started off trying to remind you to
question everything that you thought you
knew
but this is fairly happy to say i think
we all agree on this right
now the reason why this is
instrumentally better to think about is
because
it's easy to say that something is
positive rather than make a direct
comparison between the
size of these two things or i guess we
could also say if i had the direction of
the inequality facing the other
direction
a is less than b then what i'd want to
prove is that a minus b
is less than zero so what are your ways
to do that
there's a few different ways for
instance if you want to prove
that something is positive right
i can say for all values of x
that are real remember i said to you
we're not worrying about complex numbers
for now
for all values of x that are real i'm
going to have
x squared i can make a statement about
its sign
can't i right it's positive or negative
enough um if it's real
can this number ever be negative the
answer is no
so we would say this is a non-negative
number it doesn't have to be positive
though because it could of course be
equal to
zero so we uh include the boundary does
that make sense
so you can say look if i can get some
square in there then happy times i can
prove that it's equal to
or greater than zero and then you need
to deal with that equal to case
right one of the ways could we do this
well if i said to you here's
another strategy if i said to you i have
two positive numbers
a and b right what can you tell me about
the product
of those two numbers the product is also
positive right so these imply that a b
is greater than zero if so if the object
that you're interested in
can be stated as some kind of product
you can factorize it in some nice neat
way
that i look at each of the independent
factors and they're both positive
then then i'm done right and i'll just
come back to this one
over here sometimes you can get a one
over a
in your expression you're like oh i got
to here well what that implies
is something about its reciprocal what's
the what can you tell me about the sign
of the reciprocal of say a positive
number if i said this
is positive what can you tell me that's
reciprocal
yeah it changes magnitude but it will
not change sign right so this is also
going to be a mechanism
that we can use to prove that something
is positive